sir N'awlins weekly pay $1500 she's paid
17 and a half percent annual leave
waiting when she goes on holidays all
right first thing to notice and
admittedly it's a under it's an
understandable error however I want you
to have a look at the working that is
there I want you to compare it to you're
working one of the most common errors
when were having a look through is to
say not this but this
where does that come from now that's
smart it's not crazy where does it come
from it comes from we usually think okay
four weeks is how long you take leave
form however when you have a look it
doesn't say anything about how long
she's actually taken it yeah if it's
full weight it could just as easily have
been three or two or one in this case
right so being at all you've got his
weekly that's what was given okay let's
look at Brianna she's got her gross
fortnightly income it's fine of $2,000
four hundred dollars deducted for tax
okay so you can see she pays nine
percent of her gross pay into
superannuation even though that said
second in the question why does it make
sense to do that line of working first
here why is that know her her cool
question what do you think
okay so you can't go ahead any further
than the question before you say look
she's paying 9% of her gross pay right
so it's not 9% after she deducts the tax
it's 9% before she tucks the tax that
makes sense so that's why that the 0.09
gets calculated first and then the tax
comes out later okay
questions see have a look what do you
think are the sneaky parts of this
question what do you reckon what's
sneaky about this have a look can you
see the working okay so this is actually
a lot of different traps but the first
thing is to say look the question is
mainly talking in fortnight's right
eighteen thirty dollars tax after-tax
that's her income and the question
itself is about savings per fortnight
but but none of the actual piece of
information in the question two three
four are provided in fort notes I agree
that's pretty sneaky but it's not hard
to convert from weeks into four nights
you just double them it is more tricky
and this is why there are three marks on
it it is more tricky to turn monthly
into weekly now just have a look at the
working again let me zoom in a little
business so do you see what's happened
right what's a common but incorrect way
to turn months in two weeks you divide
by four and most I'm sorry you actually
turn about four nights which is correct
if you're turning into weeks we think
almost months have four weeks in them
but of course actually only one the
earliest single month in the entire year
there's four weeks only February and
only 75% of time because I'll be P use
so therefore if you're trying to convert
to five fortnight's this is true you're
trying to convert to four notes right so
what they've done is you turn that into
times 12 which is what what does that
represent now that's annual and you say
there are 26 fortnight per annum does
that make sense so that's where that 120
figure comes from and then the I think
that's the hardest part the rest of it
you saw the proceeds from there okay
all right let's move down okay now let
me just come right now the gate and say
wasn't very happy with this question
okay
however at the same time at the same
time what could have worked it out so
let's think firstly what's the total
fortnightly full pension for a couple
okay now there's the word there that
most people missed right there it says
five hundred and thirty six dollars and
seventy cents each so that's per person
per person okay it's a bit sneaky right
but then again
okay now you by the way so people ask ya
well isn't it isn't it this is per
single and this is per couple now look
for a second and think there's part of
the information in there that sort of
clues you into the fact that of course
it has to be per individual what is it
yeah that's kind of a bitter it's like
this person is getting more these people
need more but they're getting less as a
whole couple that can't be right so you
see when you so these other things ought
to be worked out okay that makes a lot
more sense and the same so yeah again
yes yes people do get it right okay now
yeah and then the government comes in
look see paper now yes
when you say it says Kevin Alex are
eligible for the pension now what was
hard to interpret here and I get you
know yes okay so the question was wait
so our human Alex like wait you don't
even know are they is that a man and
woman are they both dudes and they both
like these are the worst choice of names
ever anyway so it doesn't tell you but
here's two things you can do number one
you can read the cue from part one can
read the cue from part one it tells you
tell me about a couple right that's the
first thing
secondly even if you went ahead and you
said yet note these are two completely
separate people you could say in your
answer these are two separate you mean
these are two separate people because
you haven't told me and then you can go
ahead and solve the question
okay now in all seriousness when a
question - like I've seen I've seen
papers not like this where there's
actually something wrong that's in a
question like is in there will be some
part up here and then you need to use
that but then it's incorrect okay now
you can go ahead and you can take on the
based on the fact that and then you go
for it because look this three hallmarks
here right if your assumption is one
that's at maximum one thing that you're
going to be penalized for but assuming
you do all rest of these things here are
which are to do with this question early
and regardless of me a couple or not
then you're going to get those marks
okay if the HSC markers are paid to look
at solutions that are wrong but have
right parts of the logic in them so
there's a good chance you'll get two out
of three which is fine a lot of people
really got to our three even when they
had the right assumption okay so just
include that and again you can see in
this solution you can have more detail
here but it's really important you put
this stuff here okay you guys did pretty
well partly because we talked about it
so much but they were still throughout
the whole grade and in this class people
who only really put in these numbers
here and sort of expected number one us
to be able to read your mind and work
out what on earth that's string of
unrelated numbers here and number two
expected that you yourself would not get
mixed up and that was an easy thing to
get confused you've got five different
four different equations there and you
can borrow them off very easily okay any
questions before I move on let's have a
look at youth allowance this was less
confusing them in the only one mark
questions so Vicky's a single parent
who's unemployed so you just had to read
there it is there are 143 what's the
maximum total income that she could earn
so you can see when it says maximum
total income that means you can include
the youth allowance that's part of your
income
well I'll think about it right sorry
what do you mean like as in in the
previous test yeah okay so I I'm taking
my cue from the words maximum and total
does that make sense like I'm looking
for more than one thing so as in and
besides the fact that if you had written
143 you're answering the previous
question yeah does that make sense okay
all right so that's the end of question
21